let's say that Y is equal to sine of x
squared to the third power which of
course we could also write as sine of x
squared to the third power and will work
curious about is what is the derivative
of this with respect to X what is dy/dx
which you can also write as Y prime well
there's a couple of ways to think about
it this isn't a straightforward
expression here but you might notice
that I have something being raised to
the 3rd power in fact if we look at the
outside of this expression we have some
business in here it's being raised to
the 3rd power and so one way to tackle
this is to apply the chain rule so if we
apply the chain rule it's going to be
the derivative of the outside with
respect to the inside or the something
to the third power the derivative of the
something to the third power with
respect to that something so it's going
to be three times that something squared
times the derivative with respect to X
of that something in this case this
something is signed we write that in the
blue color it is sine of x squared it is
sine of x squared if I no matter what
was inside of these orange parentheses I
would put it inside of the orange
parentheses and these orange brackets
right over here we learned that in the
chain rule so let's see we know this is
just a matter the first part of the
expression is just a matter of algebraic
simplification but the second part we
need to now take the derivative of sine
of x squared well now we would want to
use the chain rule again so I'm going to
take the derivative its sine of
something so this is going to be the
derivative of this it's going to be the
sine of something with respect to
something so that is cosine of that
something times the derivative with
respect to X of the something in this
case the something is our x squared and
if
course we have all of this out front
which is the three times sine of x
squared I could write it like this
squared all right
so we're getting close now we just to
figure out the derivative with respect
to X of x squared and we've seen that
many times before that we just use the
power rule that's going to be 2x 2x and
so if we wanted to write being the dy/dx
you get a little bit of a mini drumroll
here this shouldn't take us too long
dy/dx I'll multiply the 3 times the 2x
which is going to be 6x so I covered
those so far times sine squared of x
squared times sine squared of x squared
times cosine of x squared and we are
done multiplying the chain rule multiple
times